inauguration du stade de france à
saint-denis 85 mille places et pas le
moindre embouteillages comme on le
redoute et en le payant république et le
gouvernement rende hommage aux trois
policiers brûlé vif au cours d'une
intervention de routine qui a basculé
sur le drame hier soir vie privée vie
publique la sphère bill clinton suivi de
près par les hommes politiques français
dans notre pays ce type de scandale n'a
jamais connu un tel retentissement
l'europe cherche une solution à l'exode
massif des kurdes ils viennent d'irak de
turquie n'ont pas d'autre solution que
la fuite à n'importe quel prix
enquête dans ce journal tennis huit ans
après yannick noah un français en demi
finale des internationaux d'australie
nicolas escudé vainqueur courageux de
l'allemand préfèrant 5
madame monsieur bonsoir pour la première
fois de son histoire la france possède
d'un grand stade digne de son football
on l'espère du moins 85 mille places
c'est le double du parc des princes et
sur sa pelouse que se déroulera la
finale de la prochaine coupe du monde de
football le stade de france à
saint-denis c'est son nom vient d'être
inaugurée ce soir par le président de la
république laurent frédéric bollée 28
janvier 1998
19h15 le spectacle peut commencer cet
instant tant attendu est enfin là le
stade de france conçue dans la douleur
s'apprête à naître dans le bonheur une
inauguration rassemblant d'abord 1200
jeunes trois mois de répétition un coût
de 3 millions de francs la fête est
belle elle rappelle la cérémonie
d'ouverture des jeux olympiques
d'albertville
il y a 6 ans dans les tribunes la
presque totalité des 80000 spectateurs
est déjà là il fait froid très froid
mais c'est un moment qui fait chaud au
coeur de tous les amateurs de football
ce grand stade au stade de france cette
cathédrale du sport
on l'attendait depuis presqu'un siècle
serpent de mer aux chimères il a fallu
l'attribution de la coupe du monde de
football à la france en juillet 92 pour
qu'enfin ils deviennent nécessaires
incontournable et surtout construit
28 janvier 1998 19h46 l'hommage rendu à
quelques-uns des plus illustres sportif
français ils sont 23 d'alain prost à eva
serrano de stéphane peterhansel à luc
alphand
c'est alors que jacques chirac va parler
du monde
je souhaite une vie belle et glorieuse
au stade de france
le geste inaugural est donc en fait
effectué par deux jeunes de
seine-saint-denis
le ruban mesure 80 mètres de long 4
mètres cinquante de large
quand il est coupé c'est une page qui se
tourne
place maintenant aux sports et à sa
légende
ce stade les amateurs de football et
plus généralement de sport et de grand
spectacle attendait depuis très
longtemps et dès le milieu de l'après
midi ils se pressaient autour de
l'enceinte du nouveau stade de france à
saint-denis
non sans une certaine émotion d'ailleurs
yann lavoix en régie à l'extérieur
magnifique une histoire bien à
l'intérieur
vous êtes impatients 8 vite ils sont un
petit peu moins de 79 me avoir bravé le
froid de ces instants historiques et
découvrir le stade de france mais jojo
tu dois savoir qu'en france les gens
heureux pour toujours moins de bruit que
les râleurs non mais c'est vrai que les
portes se sont ouvertes avec un peu de
retard et que les places de parking sont
rares mais de là tout leur remette en
question
ouais mais c'est pas normal quoi on
avait de la place ailleurs qu'à saint
denis pour construire un stade de 80000
basse malheureux
heureusement que l'inoxydable manolo lui
a le sourire
c'est se voiler son billet explique-t-il
il n'a pas voulu qu'il soit déchiré au
guichet afin que son souvenir reste
entier et puis il ya le choc la
rencontre frontale avec la reine est là
le vocabulaire manque un peu grandiose
il ment ce fabuleux à lui seul ce jeune
homme a employé les trois qualificatifs
les plus à la mode au stade de france ce
soir
oh non
en fait jojo pour que la fête soit
totale il n'y a plus qu'à espérer que
les joueurs ne soient pas trop paralysé
par ce décor
comment dit on déjà ah oui grandiose le
stade de france à saint-denis étant
situés en ville et n'offrant
volontairement que 6000 places de
parking pour encourager l'accès par les
transports en commun la grande la très
grande inquiétude des organisateurs et l
encombrement monstre d'autant que dans
un premier temps une grève à la ratp
était prévu qui heureusement a été évité
et bien finalement tout s'est passé
comme personne ne l'avait imaginé c'est
à dire qu'il n'y a pratiquement pas une
circulation sur le périphérique cet
après midi et que les spectateurs qui
ont emprunté des transports en commun se
sont montrés très très disciplinés
olivier caroff mathieu jamais sans doute
autoroute nord et l'a86 n'avait présenté
un tel visage sur le coup des 17 heures
circulation plus que fluide selon les
spécialistes
à tel point que les joueurs de l'équipe
de france sont arrivés largement en
avance 17h15 les voilà au stade ils vont
y passer trois heures à attendre
à la même heure certains de leurs
supporters malgré les conseils des
autorités avaient choisi la sacro sainte
bagnole
malgré la mauvaise impression laissée
par le tout premier match au stade de
france
daniel s'en souvient encore ju superpi à
18h32 porte d'orléans
je suis arrivé à 20h40 dans le parking
non et si aujourd'hui je fais la même
chose quoique la fois je me posais la
question si je dois y retourner mais
cette fois ci entre supporters on avait
parié et pas que sur le score du match
et on a dit qu'on arrivait plus vite que
nos copains qui eux sont métro est grave
mais par contre sans griller les feux
auto route parfaitement dégagées baril
gagne la ratp a elle aussi gagné son
pari les supporters ont eu le réflexe
ticket choc
tout s'est passé dans le calme au rythme
des guitares et du flamenco
pour l'instant tout va bien maintenant
on espère par ailleurs comme il faut ça
la maison un calme relatif
les supporters sont fidèles à leur
réputation de boute en train
mais les conducteurs prennent les choses
avec le sourire de toute façon pour le
public
c'était le métro ou le match à la
technique n'est ce pas trop le choix
mais qu à 5000 places mais uniquement
sur invitation je pense que les gens
sont résignés à prendre les transports
j'ai mon beauf qui doivent avoir un plan
parking au c'est bien regardant les t45
à l'intérieur du stade au poste de
commandement c'est le soulagement pour
les transports et la sécurité première
mi temps réussis sur place notable de
france à bord nicosie tous les
pronostics les plus pessimistes ont été
déjoués alban effectivement il y avait
cinq scénarios il vient c'est le plus
optimiste qui a été le scénario qui
s'est réalisé puisque 80 mille personnes
ont donc pris place dans ce stade
vous voyez juste derrière moi
l'autoroute a86 qui est toujours déserte
on y as très bien circulé toute la
journée
soixante quinze voitures ont été enlevés
par là par la fourrière ces deux
voitures mal garées c'est tout ce qu'il
ya à déplorer
la gare rer a donc parfaitement joué son
rôle voyelles est situé à une dizaine de
minutes à pied
maintenant c'est un premier test qui
réussit il faudra attendre la
confirmation ce soir avec les retours
80000 personnes vont se presser à la
sortie du stade
à 23 heures pour rentrer chez elles le
plus vite possible parce qu'il fait très
froid entre -3 et -5° ici merci bomiko
si les autres grands titres de
l'actualité m'en rends service c'est ce
que l'on retiendra du drame qui s'est
déroulé hier soir boulevard de la
chapelle à paris trois policiers qui
intervenaient pour tenter de mettre un
terme à une violente querelle familiale
ont été brûlés vifs par un homme qui les
a aspergés d'essence avant de mettre fin
à ses jours les trois policiers étaient
âgées de 35 27 25 ans arnaud bouteille
bernard appel
lorsque les corps des trois policiers
sortent de l'immeuble leurs collègues
fonctionnaires sont au garden silence de
circonstance boulevard de la chapelle
devant le passage des civières
les visages cache mal les motions vers
20 heures hier soir deux policiers
stagiaires âgés de 25 et 27 ans et un
brigadier de 35 ans interviennent pour
régler un différend familial
au moment de pénétrer dans l'appartement
ils sont aspergés d'essence
les trois policiers périssent brûlé
ainsi que l'incendié
je crois que ça permet d'apprécier les
risques d'un métier difficile au service
de nos concitoyens de leur liberté au
moment de l'explosion
un gardien de la paix se trouvait en
retrait dans l'escalier il a été
grièvement brûlé les seuls rescapés du
drame sont la belle soeur du forcené et
sa jeune fille l'individu est un
égyptien de 46 ans sans papiers ni
casier judiciaire précise la police
parce que le drame puis d'imprévisible
plusieurs syndicats rappellent les
dangers de la profession aujourd'hui
devant le commissariat du 10ème
arrondissement le drapeau était en berne
mais en la république le premier
ministre ont également rendu hommage aux
policiers tués soulignant à cette
occasion combien la tâche quotidienne de
ces hommes étaient indispensables
souvent routinière mais pouvant basculer
à tout moment dans la violence et le
danger thiery curtet la jambe imola le
poste de commandement c'est ici que l'on
coordonne l'action de police pour
minimiser les risques pour recueillir
dès le départ le maximum
l'information car les unités de police
secours en uniforme et aux fourgons
siglé sont en première ligne
elles interviennent leur vacation dur
parfois
l'éleveur quelques fois on a
l'impression d'intervenir sur les mêmes
situations et effectivement quelques
fois en 11 10 on dit c'est la même
situation que celle d'avant donc ans
on fait moins attention peut-être mais
ladite un problème il faut faire
attention à tout
ouais enfin l'attention cinq ou six
alarme de banque ou de commerce qu'ils
seul pour rien deux ou trois différents
familiaux tous les jours
finissent par émousser leur vigilance
ils sont forts sur le jeu dangereux
cette fois les renseignements sont
maigres un voisin qui signale des cris
des pleurs dans l'appartement d'à côté
en même temps faut laisser ou la
mauvaise course et moi la tendresse que
je continue ma vie le train vers la
france veut fermer pendant que les
convives on espère aller loin derrière
car mais posons ancien des mesures de
protection minimum mais qui n'ont rien
de dérisoire
l'expérience du terrain facture font
partie la sécurité en partie seulement
car pour eux le risque zéro n'existe pas
d'un incendie du siège du crédit
lyonnais en mai 85,16 pardon à paris
était bel et bien d'origine criminelle
comme nous l'affirmions déjà dans notre
magazine envoyé spécial il ya bien eu
deux départs de feu dans un pré-rapport
remis au juge d'instruction les experts
sont formels sur ce point jean pierre
métier il ya bien eu deux départs de feu
ce matin là deux foyers totalement
distincts sans communication l'un avec
l'eau le feu aux lyonnais ressemble
bigrement un incendie criminel
l'information est confirmée aujourd'hui
dans un rapport d'experts remis au juge
martin bernard
celle ci va donc reprendre l'instruction
sur cette hypothèse criminelle en
entendant de nouveaux témoins les
vigiles les pompiers les entreprises
sous traitants ce soir le crédit
lyonnais annonce qu'il s'est porté
partie civile et souhaite que la lumière
soit faite mais si l'incendié était bien
criminel
difficile de savoir qui pourrait en être
l'auteur tant les affaires sulfureuses
pullulent dans les dossiers du lyonnais
un certain nombre de documents sensibles
sont partis en fumée
les archives de la direction
internationale notamment et puis autre
coïncidence à laquelle le juge pourra
s'intéresser un curieux cambriolage rues
de hanovre aux deuxième et troisième
étages d'une annexe du crédit lyonnais
la dl directions informatiques et
logistiques chargés de la maintenance
des bâtiments et contenant les plans de
la banque des disquettes et du matériel
informatique auraient été dérobés
c'était cinq jours avant l'incendié dans
la nuit du 30 avril
au 1er mai une curieuse coïncidence
après les perquisitions dans le bureau
et les différents domiciles de roland
dumas le président du conseil
constitutionnel les juges chargés de la
faire de pots de vin à l'occasion d'un
marché militaire avec taïwan cherche à
savoir en fait si l'ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères de françois
mitterrand est directement impliqué dans
le dossier s'il a lui même bénéficié
d'une partie de cet argent pour
l'instant il faut tout de même rappeler
que roland dumas n'est encore entendu
que comme témoin dominique verdeilhan
claude a dans ses cartons ont été
emportés des carnets des agendas
appartenant à roland dumas mais les deux
juges ont également saisi des documents
bancaires les magistrats s'intéresse aux
comptes privés de l'ancien ministre dans
une agence crédit lyonnais
proche de son domicile et plus
particulièrement à des versements qui
s'élèverait à 10 millions de francs
question y at il un lien entre cet
argent et la vente par thomson de six
frégates à taïwan seulement les deux
juges avance juridiquement en terrain
miné rulan dumars actuel président du
conseil constitutionnel n'est protégé
par aucune immunité
mais c'est son passage au quai d'orsay
qui doit inciter les juges à la prudence
soit les faits éventuellement reprochées
à roland dumas sont d'ordre privé alors
les juge eva joly et laurence michel qui
sont compétentes et peuvent poursuivre
leur instruction soit roland dumas a agi
dans l'exercice de ses fonctions de
ministre des affaires étrangères le
dossier serait alors du ressort de la
cour de justice
toute erreur de procédure entraînerait
l'annulation du dossier côté politique
on se félicite de l'indépendance des
juges
je crois qu'il est normal que les juges
développe
leurs investigations voilà maintenant je
n'en ferai pas plus je passe plus de
commentaires plusieurs jours devraient
donc être nécessaire aux juges pour
éplucher les documents saisis
un laps de temps durant lequel roland
dumas ne peut pas se défendre
juridiquement peut-être un pavé dans la
mare au procès de maurice papon à
bordeaux l'un des avocats des parties
civiles maître arno klarsfeld met en
cause le président de la cour d'assises
jean louis castagnède il affirme qu'un
membre de sa famille à échapper aux
rafles reproché à maurice papon pour
l'avocat cela peut mettre en cause son
impartialité dans la conduite du procès
à perpignan 2e jour du procès de patrick
tissier auteur d'un double assassinat
dont la petite karine huit ans les
circonstances particulièrement
douloureuses du viol et du meurtre de la
petite fille ont été évoqués aujourd'hui
ballet lhermitte bono giraudeau
marie-josée goze l'unique témoin vivant
de l'extrême violence des patrick
tissier s'avance doucement vers la barre
elle n'a rien oublié de cette nuit du 10
septembre 93 étranglée et laissée pour
morte par tissier
au risque de choquer dit elle pour ceux
qui ont été assassinés ces terribles
mais eux - sont morts car survivra
tissier bois est insurmontable
le terrible face à face entre
l'étrangleur et ses victimes a commencé
il a essayé
de s'excuser auprès de moi mais ça je ne
peux pas l'accepter
la mère de la petite karine voltaire est
revenu à l'audience elle se croyait prêt
à tout entendre
mais tout est insupportable tissier que
le président a mis en confiance raconte
l'enlèvement les menottes
le viol les tremblements la mort la
merde et karine se lève
elle craque et hurle son chagrin fait
particulièrement émouvant de voir cette
femme quitter la salle alors qu'elles
voudraient y rester pour la mémoire de
sa fille mais elle n'y arrive pas elle
ne peux pas et je ne sais pas si elle
pourra venir de même témoigné à
l'intérieur dans la salle le public est
en pleurs et feinte ou non une larme
coule aussi sur l'ajout des pâtissiers
le président suspend l'audience dans la
sphère du meurtre de sophie toscan du
plantier assassiné en décembre 96 en
irlande l'homme qui a été interpellé
hier était un voisin de la victime il a
été relâché après l'accord va devoir ce
n'est pas la première fois qu'il est
entendu par la police
irlande en france 2000 étudiants des iut
dans les rues de rennes des
manifestations dans plusieurs autres
villes de france pour protester contre
un projet de réforme de ces instituts
universitaires de technologie qui
connaissent un réel succès parmi les
étudiants 115 mille étudiants suivent la
formation courte de deux ans des 8es le
plus souvent en phase avec les besoins
industriels des régions où ils sont
implantés ces étudiants sont très
demandés les étudiants des iut sont donc
opposés à une réforme d'un système qui
se re fonctionne très bien comme ça
reportage à tour jean bernard schmidt
quatrième manifestation au moins de
trois semaines pour edith est toujours
la même ferveur
étudiante en première année à l'institut
universitaire de technologie de tours ai
dit fais grève comme ses camarades pour
protester contre des réformes qui
remettent en cause selon elle la
spécificité des iut encore la
dévalorisation du diplôme on craint que
que les jours une fois plus vite et que
me l'étais avant et nous regarder mais
les avantages qu'on avait avant veut on
veut en votre chambre partie
conventionnelle on veut être
on veut pas être comme les autres on
veut pas ou parce qu'on a un bts à une
fois qu'on veut en fait différents
depuis un mois luttez tourmen la
contestation nationale par le biais du
téléphone et d'internet
les étudiants tourangeau tiennent au
courant les autres instituts l'évolution
des revendications un projet ministériel
visant à changer le système de notation
les critères de recrutement ainsi que le
fonctionnement budgétaire de ces
établissements une réforme qui pourrait
nuire au succès que connaissent les iut
filière universitaire courte et
professionnels les iut c'est une
réussite au sein d'universités ce n'est
pas un hasard c'est fondé sur des atouts
en particulier la maîtrise du
recrutement de nos étudiants des
enseignants une ligne budgétaire propre
une pédagogie un enseignement spécifique
ce sont ses atouts qui sont remis en
cause pourrait vite comme pour les 1200
étudiants de l'iut de tours pas question
de faiblir et ce malgré les tentatives
de conciliation faite par claude allègre
demain c'est sans illusions qu'ils se
rendront à une table ronde au ministère
de l'éducation
la personnalité tonitruante de marc
blondel ne laisse pas indifférent
l'opinion publique mais elle provoque
aussi des temps gage sérieux au sein de
son syndicat force ouvrière aujourd'hui
son principal adversaire à l'intérieur
de fo jacques mairet a décidé de claquer
la porte en compagnie d'environ 3000
militants et il ne mâche pas ses mots
laurent bailly et patrick fois c'est
officiel depuis ce matin le principal
opposant de marc blondel jacques mére
ici à gauche quitte force ouvrière et
rejoint l'union des syndicats autonomes
un transfert qui fait du bruit jacques
mére jusqu'ici responsable de la
puissante fédération fo de paris emmène
dans son sillage dit il plus de 3000
militants de force ouvrière fo qui à ses
yeux aurait perdu son indépendance et
jacques mary accuse même marc blondel de
manipulation politique
il y a de plus en plus à la direction de
force ouvrière dans ses différentes
structures la mainmise d'une secte
politique qui s'appelle le parti des
travailleurs qui est un parti d'extrême
gauche trotskiste quand il parle de ce
genre de choses je me demande s'il fume
pas un joint s'il n'ya pas facile et pas
un petit peu halluciné par ses phobies
car en définitive ya pas plus de
militants trotskistes la force ouvrière
qu'il ya 15 ans en dépit des apparences
la querelle entre les deux hommes est
ancienne en 96 lors d'un congrès elle
tourne al'avantage de marc blondel
largement réélu secrétaire général au
détriment de jacques mére en fait le
candidat malheureux a toujours reproché
à marc blondel d'avoir trahi la
politique contractuelle chère à andré
bergeron en privilégiant au contraire un
syndicalisme très contestataire
aujourd'hui la page mais ray se tourne
il est encore trop tôt pour dire s'il
s'agit d'un point final à la crise
interne ou seulement d'une étape
l'actualité internationale le feuilleton
des démêlés de bill clinton avec la
justice américaine en attendant
l'audition de monica levinsky amie
présumée du président qui aurait fait un
faux témoignages en sa faveur
bill clinton fait face avec brio on l'a
vu hier soir l'occasion son traditionnel
discours sur l'état de l'union prononcé
devant les parlementaires américains à
washington
maryse burgot il est 21h hier soir
devant lui
paul gray le président américain n'a pas
encore commencé son discours
mais à l'image de sa femme hillary la
salle est déjà debout pour l'applaudir
bill clinton dopé par le soutien appuyé
de ses alliés démocrates fait une très
honorable prestation
pas un mot sur le scandale en cours le
président américain s'appuie d'abord sur
son bilan économique convaincre
l'hémicycle
cette année d'avant notre déficit
budgétaire devrait être de seulement 10
milliards de dollars et cela va encore
baisser
vinton tifa l'hémicycle la tête haute
prêt à continuer à travailler pour son
pays comme il le dit dès ce matin il
était d'ailleurs dans l'illinois pour
parler d'éducation soutien appuyé du
vice président al gore et là aussi
tonnerre d'applaudissements la maison
blanche tente l'impossible pour faire
oublier l' affaire monica levinsky mais
les médias eux ne lâchent pas le
scandale
cet enseignant de 32 ans affirme
aujourd'hui avoir eu lui aussi une
liaison avec levinsky la jeune femme lui
aurait alors confié avoir eu une
relation sexuelle avec un personnage
haut placée à la maison blanche
pendant ce temps la chambre d'accusation
chargée de l'enquète continue à entendre
les témoins hier c'était la secrétaire
particulière de bill clinton
effrayés par les caméras aujourd'hui
c'est au tour de l'ancien secrétaire
général de la maison blanche
l' enquête sur la sphère levinsky va
maintenant suivre son cours et le
président pendant ce temps veut
travailler son épouse il arrive déclare
ce matin qu'il ne s'exprimera plus
publiquement sur ces accusations de
parjure et d'infidélité la prochaine
fois qu'il le fera ce sera chez le juge
chargé de l'enquêté
le discours prononcé hier soir par bill
clinton a permis aux américains de
scruter si je puis dire le moral et la
forme de leur président face aux
attaques mais ce discours avait
également un autre objet mettre en garde
le président irakien saddam hussein qui
pour les états unis continuent de se
soustraire à une véritable inspection de
son
temps ciel militaire réelle jean-marc il
use je sais que je peux parler en votre
nom
républicains comme démocrates quand je
dis à saddam hussein vous ne pouvez pas
défier le monde entier derrière ces
applaudissements hier soir au congrès de
washington la volonté réaffirmée de
l'amérique de recourir s'il le faut à la
force pour désarmer l'irak car depuis
octobre la crise couve et plus de 25
mille soldats américains sont de nouveau
sur le pied de guerre dans le golfe
objectif convaincre saddam hussein de
cesser d'entraver le travail des
inspecteurs des nations unies en matière
de désarmement et d'armes de destruction
massive
oui mais voilà depuis une dizaine de
jours saddam hussein brusquement durci
sa position même plus question de
négocier un droit de regard des nations
unies sur les sites dits présidentielle
toujours inaccessible aux inspecteurs
leur chef l'australien richard butler
expliquera au secrétaire général des
nations unies que saddam dissimulent
toujours des armes dévastatrices capable
de détruire tel aviv précisera-t-il au
new york dan déclarations qui provoquent
un début d'affolement chez les
israéliens et un retour en force du
masque à gaz à bagdad aussi on fait
comme si
et la propagande veut mobiliser un
million de volontaires
même les femmes et les vieillards
psychologie de guerre alors parce qu'il
devient urgent de calmer le jeu le chef
de la diplomatie russe et spécialiste de
l'irak monsieur primakov a fait le
voyage de paris
saddam doit renoncer à ses exigences
disent aussi bien les russes que les
français mais la négociation politique
doit continuer absolument jeudi que le
recours à la force dans les situations
que nous connaissons n'est pas
souhaitable que selon notre analyse il
ne résoudrait pas les problèmes auxquels
nous nous heurtons à bagdad
un autre émissaire russe est à les
rappeler à saddam hussein que sur le
plan humanitaire comme sur celui du
désarmement des propositions plus
avantageuse pour l'irak était toujours
sur la table
mais saddam hussein en voudra-t-il cette
fois pour en revenir à ces affaires de
fraude est né du recours un faux
témoignage la part de bill clinton vient
cette affaire ne laisse pas indifférent
la classe politique française reste à
savoir si de telles révélations
intéresserait les français si elles sont
possibles dans la mesure où notre
législation est beaucoup plus strictes
en matière de respect de la vie privée
des hommes politiques chefs vite imbert
hongrie sera sur ce sujet là au moins la
classe politique française parle d'une
seule voix la vie sexuelle la vie privée
c'est une question personnelle et le
grand déballage de la sphère clinton
choc à droite comme à gauche chacun
citoyen normal président a droit à son
jardin secret à ses relations d'amitié
et pourquoi pas d'amour et cela ne
regarde personne d'autre
ni les journaux ni la magistrature ni
aucune autre autorité
personne ne prend le
le même ascenseur quand on est un
responsable d'une entreprise avec une
collaboratrice pas ce qu'ils vont faire
très attention là bas on est
immédiatement accusé de harcèlement
sexuel etc
on est je crois dont l'on met dans la
folie personne ne comprend l'ampleur
prise par cette affaire aux états unis
même lorsqu'on défend la cause du
féminisme
même lorsqu'on se bat depuis toujours
contre le harcèlement sexuel
c'est un dévoiement donc de ce fait là
et une utilisation de ce qui est une
conquête des féministes à des fins
politicienne de déstabilisation suite à
un complot en france le droit est très
claire l'article 9 du code civil établi
le respect de la vie privée l'article
226 du code pénal punit sévèrement sa
violation ou la monarchie la france a
beaucoup souffert du mélange des
affaires publiques et privées quand le
roi avait des maîtresses et des bâtards
qu'il voulait légitimer et depuis la
révolution
on a toujours voulu mettre une grande
coupure entre l'exercice de la politique
et la vie privée
la presse américaine elle regarde les
moeurs françaises deuil étonné l'exemple
le plus souvent cités c'est françois
mitterrand et sa deuxième famille si
longtemps caché pour ces journalistes là
la vie privée ne doit pas être une
barrière
si la presse li par politesse on ne
parle pas ces histoires là parce que ce
sont les histoires privées
est-ce que de temps en temps on n'oublie
pas que dans cette histoire privée il ya
des choses qui touchent les lecteurs la
personne le contribuable vie publique
vie privée en france décidément la
discrétion est de mise
cette réflexion
avec l'arrivée massive de réfugiés
kurdes sur les côtes italiennes ces
dernières semaines la communauté
européenne cherche une solution pour
tenter d'endiguer cet afflux notre
enquête de ce soir nous emmène à
istanbul d'où proviennent ces exilés du
désespoir ces familles kurdes victimes
d'un conflit intérieur à la turquie et
l'on comprend mieux pourquoi ces hommes
ces femmes
donc une seule solution finalement quel
que soit le risque et le pris la fuite
philippe rochot jean-louis nantes c'est
sur ces quais d'istanbul que c'est
négocier le départ vers l'italie de plus
d'un millier de kurdes dont le
débarquement attente inquiète et
l'europe au début de l'année kurdes de
turquie ou d'irak chassés par la guerre
ils se retrouvent tous dans cette ville
devenue plaque tournante de
l'immigration clandestine
mir année candidats à l'exil et se
cachent dans les bas quartiers
d'istanbul avec ses cinq enfants sa
femme et sa mère nihrane et sa famille
sont les victimes de la guerre sans
pitié que se livrent l'armée turque le
pkk le parti des travailleurs du
kurdistan dans l'est du pays
les soldats en brûler son village de
hyères d'airé 300 habitants et les
familles ont dû prendre la fuite vers
istanbul dans mon village soit les gens
sont partis à l'étranger sont morts au
combat des larmes et bruno maison et il
ya beaucoup de torture c'est pour ça
qu'on s'est en fait mais de notre côté
il n'y a pas de vie pour nous ici c'est
toujours la torture la fuite jusqu'au
matin je ne peux pas m'en sortir alors
qu'au fond et moi aussi je suis turc
même si la police scène où julien par
exemple j'essaie de vendre des moules
pour vivre mais la police arrive et
renversent les plateaux je n'ai donc pas
d'autre issue que de partir mirana tenté
par deux fois de quitter la turquie pour
l'europe par deux fois il a échoué
tous les kurdes qui se retrouvent à
istanbul tentent leur chance pour le
rock
ceux qui restent sont les plus démunis
ceux qui n'ont pas pu payer les 10 mille
francs qu'il faut donner aux
intermédiaires pour s'assurer un passage
vers l'italie alors ils sont recueillis
là dans cette association créée il ya
quelques mois avec le feu vert du
gouvernement
mais pour eux partir pour l'europe ou
rester en turquie le change rien à leur
baisse la tête
le salut pour nous ce n'est ni de
respect ici à istanbul ni de partir à
l'étranger et l'instant je ne peux plus
vivre chez moi dans mon village à cause
de la guerre que je sois en turquie ou à
l'étranger
c'est à peu près la même chose c'est la
nuit que les kurdes négocié leur passage
pour l'europe dans ses hôtels à 10
francs la chambre du quartier de coups
de soupe bazar les intermédiaires les
dépouilles souvent de leur économie est
la presse accuse même la police de
toucher de l'argent dans cette affaire
ce fut le cas pour les deux bateaux qui
ont accosté en italie au début de
l'année
le premier bateau à la latte pour passer
les pour traverser les dardanelles jeu
seulement 250 millions de livres tube de
pots-de-vin n'a été donnée selon
certains informations afin que la police
ferme les yeux pendant que le bateau
traverse les dardanelles donc il ya d'un
côté les pots-de-vin
de l'autre côté il ya toute cette ces
bandes qui organise ces départs de
l'intérieur des banques peuvent foyer
des autorités même s'ils n'y sont pas et
il ferme les yeux quand ils reçoivent le
pot-de-vin régulièrement pourtant la
police fédérale dans le quartier de
kuching bazar pour arrêter les
clandestins pas spécialement les kurdes
mais aussi les africains et pakistanais
qui transitent par là ce sont eux
d'ailleurs qui tombe le plus facilement
dans les filets de la police car il ne
bénéficie pas des mêmes complicités que
les kurdes dans la ville
ici ce sont des somaliens et des
tanzaniens qui voulait gagner l'europe
et squattaient un sous-sol pas de kurdes
dans cette rafle mais la police turque
se vendent dans avoir arrêté cinq sens
en une seule nuit au début de l'année
ni le passage vers l'europe ni ces
arrestations ne règle pourtant le
problème de ces milliers de clandestins
qui chaque jour utilisent cette plaque
tournante qui istanbul pour aller vers
une vie meilleure un français dans
l'espace léo paul rios partira demain de
la base de baïkonour en compagnie de
deux collègues russes direction la
station orbitale mir pour un séjour de
trois semaines normale donnant sur place
c'est la fusée la plus utilisée au monde
soyouz les russes l'appel l'autobus
idéal pour envoyer les cosmonautes vers
nous demain elle s'envolera pour la
mission franco russe pégase le 110e
départ alors comme depuis plus de 35 ans
soyouz est amenée sur son pas de tir en
une heure presque sans précaution une
technologie rustique
les français eux acceptent de faire avec
ces différents de la technologie
américaine qui est beaucoup plus
sophistiqué et par contre la technologie
russe est très fiable et est costaud à
chaque veille de départ la commission
interétatique se réunit en présence de
l'équipage
toujours pour dire la même chose et tout
va bien le français néo poleya qui sera
en charge d'expérience avait dû laisser
sa place l'été dernier un ordinateur de
ce courage cause des pannes dormir pour
lui le départ est enfin proche
ça sera une journée très intense bien
sûr à la fois sur le plan émotionnel sur
le plan du
haweij proprement dit ce que je redoute
le plus c'est peut-être que il ya un
report du vol vous êtes dans un lieu
mythique depuis gagarine
la majorité des fusées russes sont
assemblés dans ces bâtiments gigantesque
ici tout le monde se prépare à l'arrivée
du premier module de la future station
internationale des mois peut-être même
quelques années de travail un second
souffle karavaïko nous en activité ces
plats peu ralenti faute de financement
le pays risque de se faire dépasser par
de nouvelles nations spatiales comme le
japon ou le brésil sur un marché capital
le lancement des constellations de
satellites ses satellites qui vont
entourer la terre pour les
communications de téléphones portables
et les réseaux informatiques
alors ici avec onur la cité des
cosmonautes
l'horizon est plutôt sombre en france
alerte à une recrudescence des cas de
coqueluche chez les adolescents et les
adultes qui risquent de la transmettre
aux nouveau-nés c'est pour cette raison
que les pouvoirs publics s'apprêtent à
lancer une campagne de vaccination plan
daniel flaysakier la quinte de toux une
inspiration bruyante comme le chant du
coq d'où le nom de la maladie
la coqueluche fait à nouveau parler
d'elle
quarante ans après le début de la
vaccination la maladie a quasiment
disparu chez les 5 7 ans mais elle fait
un retour impressionnant chez les
nourrissons les adolescents et les
adultes insuffisamment protégé par le
vaccin ces adultes vont transmettre le
bacille de l'attribution tout petit et à
cet âge quelle maladie peut être très
grave
l'enfant fait des cas prouvé que la
cancel atouts spécifiques de la
coqueluche des cartes qui peuvent être
parfois atypiques et quand on dit
atypique en médecine ça veut dire que
parfois il ya menace d' asphyxie avec
les arrêts respiratoires beaucoup nourri
son flanc petit stage en réanimation
pendant le sommeil
le protégé de nourrissons il va falloir
vacciner ceux qui le contamine les
autorités sanitaires vont bientôt
recommandé de réactiver les enfants de
11 ans comment je fais pour l'hépatite b
ou la rubéole chez les filles
point important les nouveaux vaccins
seront beaucoup mieux toléré que le
traditionnel vaccin anticoquelucheux
parce que les modes de fabrication ont
changé le premier vaccin américain
arrive dès demain en france son
concurrent franco canadien suivre alors
pour la maladie du chant du coq
ce sera peut-être le chant du cygne
tennis internationaux d'australie
défaite de mary pierce en demi finale
battu par l'une des favorites martina
hingis mes exploits de nicolas escudé
huit ans après yannick noah qualifié
pour les demi finales après sa victoire
en cinq sets sur l'allemand kiefer
kristen d'après vous c'est papa maman
ils sont à l'autre bout du fil enfin
pour l'instant le plus vite possible de
l'autre côté du globe juste derrière les
pyrénées les parents de nicolas ont
regardé le match à la maison
les volets sont fermés pas question
d'être dérangé jusqu'à la fin de la
partie mais on est plus qu'heureux on
vole un peu là parce que bon le chemin
parcouru en si peu de temps c'est
toujours quand même sur un plaisir
immense et la première des réactions
c'est énorme match de tennis le matin et
un sprint l'après midi la famille escudé
a trois heures pour rallier l'aéroport
de bordeaux alors il faut faire vite
pour pas raté l'avion et vivre en direct
le prochain match des fistons lui il a
pris son temps pour atteindre la
demi-finale de l'open d'australie à
melbourne
nicolas a ses petites habitudes
il commence par perdre les deux premiers
sets ça fait trois matches que ça dure
sans paniquer ni s'avouer vaincu escudé
reprend le dessus et rappelle à nicolas
kiefer que sur le circuit son surnom
c'est scud le français égalise à deux
manches partout
le scénario des matches précédents est à
nouveau à l'écran petite variante
l'allemand se blesse au talon d'achille
et l'appui va interrompre le match 45
minutes mais rien ne peut plus arrêter
nicolas escudé pas même l'angoissent de
servir pour une place en demi finale et
la meilleure façon c'est de monter au
filet pour gagner un troisième match
d'affilée en cinq sets 4 100e mondial
l'année dernière nicolas le scud est
propulsé en demi finale de l'open
d'australie après borotra yannick noah
escudé le troisième français à atteindre
ce stade de la compétition
il s'appelle armand cet artiste français
qui s'est installé aux états unis depuis
près de quarante ans maintenant est
enfin consacré dans son pays il expose
au musée du jeu de paume à paris
armand c'est un sculpteur ou plutôt un
assembleur comme il le dit lui-même tous
les objets et ustensiles les plus
courants lui servent à fabriquer des
oeuvres d'art georges bégoux yann
gicquel armand armand mais où la gare
saint-lazare vous connaissez alors vous
connaissez armand les valises c'est lui
armand nantes à spa il accumule avec car
cette chevelure par exemple en y
regardant de plus près et fait de pince
monseigneur quand il s'agit du petit ils
sont un peu présentes et de la manière
dont il fonctionne on a les belges qui
descendent comme ça on allait acheter en
l'air de couper vous avez le clic
armand ne se contente pas d'assemblée
les outils il s'en sert cet acte
sacrilège et au service d'une idée
généreuse dénoncer la censure dans le
monde sur la sculpture des autres armand
et des positions tranchées
il aime montrer l'intérieur des choses
je fais ce qu'on appelle des sculptures
parce que c'est très dimensionnelle mais
je fais des conglomérats d accumulation
d abaissement du même objet et ça finit
par faire un style qui peut qu'on peut
appeler de la sculpture mais ce serait
plutôt de l'assemblage quand il n'a
semble pas ils brûlent les redonne une
âme nouvelle halle objets calcinés
l'épia nous semblent des vestiges
retrouvés par des archéologues notre
société de consommation au phare man le
plus vaste terrain d'investigation
il est à la fois témoin et acteur de son
temps des aventures des objets c'est
notre aventure aussi le drame par
exemple de la masse production de lait
va de l'envahissement des aubes et ses
notes drame aussi et je suis un peu
l'illustrateur de ces phénomènes et il
prend quelquefois des colères
j'ai tout seul face au sérieux mais
c'est que dans les musées on vous prend
au sérieux chez rarement il ne manquera
pas une basket au jeu de paume voile
avant de nous quitter le rappel des
principaux titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi d'abord l'inauguration du stade
de france à saint-denis 85000 place
depuis un signal et pas le moindre
embouteillages comme on le redoutait
autour du slam voyant la quick le
premier ministre en hommage aux trois
policiers brûlé vif hier soir au cours
d'une intervention de routine qui a
basculé pour le drame à pâques
dans quelques instants la météo de
sophie davant 20h50 deux mamans pour
noël un film de télévision avec marie
josé nat
voilà je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur notre chaîne bonsoir
admirable
autre